[Musica]
il networking non è inventato nessuno
esiste dalla notte dei tempi e tutti noi
siamo networker sì lo facciamo nella
vita di tutti i giorni quando ad esempio
diciamo va in quel ristorante lì a
mangiare pesce freschissimo oppure va in
quel bar la che fanno un caffè
strepitoso e sono anche gentili
o ancora quando costruiamo il nostro
meccanico di fiducia e diciamo a
qualcuno guarda non solo è bravo e anche
onesto
anche questo è networking
ma chi di noi nel mondo del lavoro
utilizza questo strumento il networking
in modo sistemico per crescere insieme
e chi di noi si sentirebbe tranquillo
all'idea di condividere le proprie
conoscenze competenze
magari con un'azienda estranea
provate a immaginare un luogo dove tutto
questo è possibile
dove to die ma se il sicuro di ricevere
dove si vince tutti insieme perché la
fiducia fa da collante a tutto ciò che
accade sarebbe più bello il mondo del
lavoro vero e questa è la formula per
fare networking in modo efficace
provate a immaginare che un vostro
concorrente ce l'avete presente un
giorno potrebbe aiutarvi a risolvere uno
dei vostri problemi e voi farà
altrettanto con loro
provate a immaginare di poter ricevere i
feedback per sapere se le informazioni
che avete ricevuto sono corrette non
solo sono le migliori non solo in un
tempo più corto
come sarebbe lo stress della vostra
giornata lavorativa più alto o più basso
di oggi
ma parliamoci chiaro e facciamo un
passaggio insieme
ditemi chi di voi è stato tradito nel
mondo del lavoro
pieno di mani alzate
c'è qualcuno che per caso ne vuole
alzare 2
ho visto uno causato anche una gamba
pensate anche a me che ho iniziato in
mezzo alle viti bello direte voi
la natura il vino buono le viti erano
queste però
riscatto come responsabile qualità è
un'azienda che produceva proprio viti e
bulloni
poi ho fatto l'amministratore delegato
di una multinazionale ho lavorato in
italia lavorato all'estero del 2006 è
stato a fare l'imprenditore tutto questo
devo ammetterlo con un inglese da cani
in che senso direte voi per dire garcia
qualcuno dicevo good boy o ha scoperto
solo un paio d'anni fa che in inglese lo
dicono dai cani
era il 2014 andava tutto molto bene poi
vi voglio raccontare cosa mi è successo
tutto insieme
mentre stava gestendo uno dei contratti
più difficili della mia carriera
professionale
gestivo per quel progetto più di 50
persone lavoravo 12 14 ore al giorno
cosa mi è successo
la mia compagna è stata ricoverata per
una grave malattia in ospedale è stata
ma listino è stato prata e dopo lunghi
mesi per fortuna è guarita
nello stesso periodo purtroppo hanno
ricordato anche mio padre sempre per la
stessa grave malattia lui ha lottato un
leone
ma alla fine ci ha lasciati lui non ce
l'ha fatta
in quello stesso periodo il mio migliore
amico dopo 17 anni
sapete come uno realizzato nel frattempo
era diventato mio socio mi ha rubato i
clienti
tutti i clienti potete immaginare come
sono rimasto
pensate che due anni dopo quando è stato
condannato davanti al giudice ha letto
non so neanche perché l'ho fatto
come potete immaginare ero distrutto
stavo malissimo la coltellata al cuore
mi sono ammalato e mi sono dovuto curare
le ho provate tutte
psicologo agopuntura chiropratico chi
più ne ha più ne metta
e per fortuna
dopo nove mesi sono guarito soprattutto
devo dire grazie alla vicinanza delle
persone a me care
dovevo ricominciare tutto da zero
prima di tutto mi sono chiesto chi vuoi
essere una persona che aiuta gli altri a
risolvere i problemi problemi di lavoro
ovviamente pestate che mi chiamavano e
mi chiamano ancora wolf come il
personaggio di pulp fiction che risolve
i problemi poi mi son chiesto che cosa
volevo fare
volevo occuparmi di innovazione e di
trasformazione digitale e volevo fare
incontrare le persone fare networking un
termine che in italia si usava ancora
veramente poco magari qualcuno di voi se
lo ricorda si usava di più sinergia
networking è una competenza che sempre
di più dobbiamo avere nel mondo del
lavoro e dovremmo avere nel mondo lavoro
e questo non ve lo dico io lo dicono i
massimi esperti di settore tra cui seth
godin e simon sinek poi mi sono chiesto
come potevo lavorare
avevo degli attacchi di panico e non
riuscivo uscire di casa quindi dovevo
lavorare in posti dove mi sentissi bene
e soprattutto devo lavorare da remoto
oggi dopo la pandemia su capaci tutti a
lavorare da remoto anche i bambini con
la dat ma vi assicuro che nel 2015
lavorare a distanza anche con aziende
strutturate le banche le assicurazioni
era tutt'altro che facile
giusto per raccontarvene un paio mi
capitava delle risposte del tipo quel
giorno non possiamo perché la stanza
delle videoconferenze occupata la stanza
di videoconferenze oppure non possiamo
collegarci con skype perché i nostri
firewall non ce lo permettono e va beh
in questo periodo mi sono reso conto
particolarmente di quanto fosse
importante la gestione del tempo
dovevo abbandonare l'idea del
multitasking magari a qualcuno di voi ha
già capitato
dovevo suddividere la mia giornata in
sta che in tanti singoli task da 25
minuti ciascuno dove rimanere super
concentrato senza distrazioni per non
sbagliare
magari a qualcuno di voi è capitato che
mentre stavano facendo qualche cosa gli
è successo di una distrazione un video
la televisione una mail il risultato non
è venuto un granché
magari durante il look dow è successo
anche a voi questo esempio di
multitasking
poi mi sono chiesto con chi volevo
lavorare solo con persone manager che
avevano voglia di condividere le proprie
esperienze e conoscenze anche con gli
altri
sentirmi manager
insieme a questo tipo di manager e prima
di restare questo progetto nel 2015
ho chiesto a due persone che io non
conoscevo ma si presentavano come
massimi esperti di marketing
la loro opinione sul mio progetto di
fare questo modello di networking
oggi vi racconto che cosa mi hanno detto
alberto non farlo aiuto le aziende non
credono e non investono nel digitale
mamma mia nessun manager ti condividerà
mai le proprie esperienze conoscenze e
oltretutto i manager non sanno e non
vogliono fare networking
disastro
ma io ci credevo quello era il mio sogno
e non ho mollato e dopo essermi
confrontato con un paio di persone che
ritenevo veramente top abbiamo deciso di
non seguire quei consigli ed
implementare ed in creare questo modello
di networking che in italia ancora non
esisteva questo modello di networking
oggi conta più di duemila manager dove
ci confrontiamo tutti i giorni su temi
di strategie di business di innovazione
di strategia digitale
l'obiettivo del networking è sempre
organizzare l'incontro giusto nel
momento giusto con le persone giuste
e l'originalità di questo modello è che
ogni ogni manager del nostro network
chiede aiuto quando ha bisogno
in cambio fornisce la propria
disponibilità per aiutare gli altri
oppure per certificare persone fornitori
o soluzioni e l'originalità di questo
modello e che tutti un dare e ricevere
sono incentivati a partecipare
voglio spiegarvi questa slide in 20
secondi
come funziona tutte le persone del
nostro network di tutte le persone
sappiamo in che azienda lavorano cosa
fanno quali sono le sue competenze così
quando riceviamo una richiesta di aiuto
in ambito lavorativo
cosa facciamo
selezioniamo alcune di queste persone le
coinvolgiamo gli sottoponiamo la
problematica in modo anonimo loro ci
raccontano semplicemente le loro
esperienze come l'hanno risolto noi
selezioniamo quella che secondo noi è la
migliore rispetto alla richiesta e non
ci fermiamo qua cosa facciamo
chiediamo al fornitore tu perché hai
lavorato
ok
scegliamo un altro manager che abbia
lavorato presso uno di questi clienti e
gli chiediamo di verificare che abbia
lavorato veramente bene solo a questo
punto organizziamo l'incontro con chi ci
aveva fatto la richiesta e in ultimo
diamo i feedback a tutte le persone che
hanno partecipato e che sono state
coinvolte
questo modello di networking è come un
ecosistema ed è basato sulla fiducia
fiducia che quella cosa che io avevo
perso dopo essere stato tradito è
diventato il punto di forza del nostro
network
fiducia vuol dire essere presenti vuol
dire ste trasparenti fiducia vuol dire
soprattutto non tradire i propri valori
ed è grazie alla fiducia che la 84 per
cento delle nostre richieste hanno
trovato una soluzione
fiducia e anche rimanere in contatto con
le persone
ci sono mille modi ognuno può fare
quello che vuole può fare le telefonate
il messaggino la mail
gli aperitivi pranzi le cene io vi
consiglio perché mi diverto molto
io ad esempio consiglio anche un piano
di comunicazione soprattutto perché
abbiamo 2000 manager io cosa ho deciso
di fare ad esempio
due anni fa di fare delle video clip di
30 secondi dove ci mettevo la faccia e
di pubblicarli sul social network
professionale che linkedin e questi
video che iniziano tutti con ciao ciao
ciao ciao a tutti
fanno parte del network dei un giorno
intero
dedicato al network ogni mercoledì tutte
le settimane
questo è rimanere in contatto con le
persone
i video che ho girato da milano a dubai
e dal salento ai caraibi fanno
generalmente 5 mila visualizzazioni
tutte le settimane ma soprattutto io
ricevo 500 messaggi ogni settimana a cui
risponde singolarmente 1 a 1
questa è rimanere in contatto con le
persone
ci sono molte cose che ho imparato in
questa esperienza personale e
professionale
oggi voglio condividere con voi dei
primi cinque
volontà
la forza del network sta nella voglia
nel desiderio di aiutare gli altri e
anche nella velocità di dare le risposte
confronto
parlare con gli esperti di settore ci
aiuta ad ampliare i nostri orizzonti
e chiedere l'opinione a persone che noi
stimiamo sapete cosa fa ci aiuta a
capire punti di vista diversi
autorevolezza
incontrare persone i manager
imprenditori fa crescere il nostro know
how le nostre competenze e questo
aumenta la nostra autostima
feedback
il network per essere efficace ha
bisogno di cure ha bisogno di attenzioni
ha bisogno di feedback deve essere
nutrito proprio come una buona relazione
nella vita di tutti i giorni
relazioni facendo networking attraiamo
persone come noi con i nostri stessi
valori
e vi assicuro che spesso capita che
relazioni professionali si trasformino
in relazione di amicizia
però questa rivoluzione del networking
non si può fare da soli c'è bisogno di
persone aperte al cambiamento come voi
perché come sappiamo
insieme si va veloci
no da soli si va veloci
insieme si va lontano
concludo
alberto impara ad aiutare gli altri
sarà la cosa più importante in tutta la
tua vita me lo diceva sempre mio padre
ed è stato questo il consiglio che mi ha
ispirato a fare networking e che oggi
spero sia d'ispirazione anche per tutti
voi grazie
[Applauso]